Starting with this weird selector, right here,
with dollar sign open parenthesis, quotes, quotes, close parenthesis.
This is an indication that you're using jQuery.
The dollar sign parenthesis quotes syntax is only used for
jQuery, and it grabs an element on the page, which in this case,
is the class identified by this .super-header-wrapper.
We run the .html method on it, which in this case is going to replace the HTML
of everything of the class super-header-wrapper with the HTML we see right here.
In this case, this HTML is going to embed a picture.
So, when I press Enter, we can see that we've now changed the Udacity homepage
to this awesome picture of the Android teaching on the Udacity platform.
>> That is an awesome picture and just to be clear, you only made the change for
this local copy of the page, not the actual website.
So if you refresh the page, you'll see that it goes back to normal